on va voter au québec lundi les
élections de mi-mandat s'en viennent aux
états unis et l'an prochain il y aura
une campagne électorale au canada elie
campagne électorale c'est la saison de
la chasse pour les spécialistes de la
manipulation
regardez bien cette manifestation ça se
passe au texas en 2016 six mois avant
l'élection de donald trump
[Musique]
d'un côté de la rue des gens sont venus
manifester à l'invitation d'un groupe
facebook croft existent ils protestent
contre ce qu'ils appellent une
islamisation du texas et de l'autre côté
de la rue des contre manifestants
mobilisés par une autre page facebook
united minds of america une vraie manif
dans les rues de houston complètement
organisé par des comptes facebook
en russie ils ont quand même dû ça m'a
brisé des gens pour aller dans les
veines faire partager les événements
facebook sur les réseaux sociaux des
gens ce soir gino harel et luc tremblay
nous amène dans le monde du faux et de
la désinformation
bienvenue à enquête à lyon avec 2
[Musique]
un an et demi après les évènements du
houston
un comité du sénat américain a compris
pourquoi aucun organisateur des
manifestations ne s'était rendu au texas
les groupes étaient donc contrôlé à
distance par des russes a fait ces deux
groupes
cela n'existe pas donc c'est à des pages
facebook créée par cette zone à je pense
qu'il ya personne qui s'attendaient à ce
qu'il ya eu des manifestations
organisées dans la vraie vie par des
fausses pages activistes qui étaient
gérés de plage aussi
[Musique]
comment départager le vrai du faux le
décor derrière moi est faux mais au
cours des derniers mois on a mené une
vraie démarche journalistique dans le
but de découvrir les dangers du faux
vous me suivez
ça nous a permis de voir que la
désinformation commence aussi à faire
son oeuvre jusqu'ici au canada du sommet
du g7 en juin dernier
jusqu'à un site internet montréal est
surveillé par le temps parce qu'il
publierait des articles pro russie mais
revenons d'abord aux états unis
l'opération des faux comptes de réseaux
sociaux là bas a vraiment fonctionné
et pour pas cher l'objectif de la russie
c'est donc de déstabiliser nos sociétés
d'eau les fractures et c'est ce que
j'appelle pour ma part une propagande de
pyromanes l'idée c'est que vraiment on
va jeter de l'huile sur le feu
l'objectif c'est pas du tout d'essayer
de convaincre qu'il faut défendre les
droits des homosexuels ou défendre le
contrôle de l'armement ou le contraire à
la limite les russes s'en moquent
éperdument ce qui leur importe c'est de
faire en sorte que l'agressivité entre
les deux camps soient de plus en plus
forte et que tout ça fracturé nos
sociétés
[Musique]
février 2018
la justice américaine accuse treize
russes et trois compagnies dont la
fameuse internet oui search agency on
leur reproche de s'être ingéré dans le
système électoral américain en utilisant
des comptes de réseaux sociaux
quatre mois plus tard une nouvelle
frappe
les américains accusent cette fois 11
personnes reliées aux renseignements
russes de s'être introduit dans la
messagerie de courriel du parti
démocrate et de la campagne d'hillary
clinton pour en diffuser le contenu
en mai 2010 est à quelques jours de la
présidentielle française
la campagne des manuels macron a elle
aussi subi le même genre d'attaqués
arnaud mercier avait d'ailleurs analysé
la faire pour lui il est clair que la
russie à l'europe dans sa mire la russie
à neuneu n'accepte pas en terme
géopolitique
l'idée que l'union européenne devienne
une puissance donc tout ce qui divise
l'union européenne et les nations qui
composent l'union européenne est bon à
prendre
[Musique]
c'est à riga en lettonie que nous avons
rencontré arnaud mercier
ils venaient y faire une présentation en
juin dernier dans le cadre d'une
conférence organisée par le centre
d'excellence en communication
stratégique de l'otan or ici plusieurs
conférenciers décrivent les russes comme
des experts de la désinformation surtout
à l'égard des membres de l'otan on est
définitivement dans une confrontation de
l'information avec eux ils utilisent
toutes sortes de ruses contre nous franz
tost le kremlin rejette toutes ces
accusations
une porte-parole de moscou a déclaré
début 2018 la russie ne s'est jamais
géré et ne s'ingérera jamais dans les
élections d'autres pays car c'est
contraire aux principes fondamentaux de
la politique étrangère russe
il nie toujours tout il calcule que les
critiques qu'ils reçoivent pour ce
qu'ils font leur fond - de tort que les
bénéfices qu'ils croient pouvoir en
retirer
pour marc l'été aucun pays n'est à
l'abri de la désinformation et ça peut
venir de n'importe où
ceux qui font de la désinformation sur
les réseaux sociaux
le font parce que ce n'est pas cher et
qu'on peut le nier pourquoi ne pas le
faire c'est ça qui est horrible je crois
que le canada devrait prendre ça au
sérieux comme tout autre pays parce que
quiconque veut jouer dur avec vous va
tout de suite pensé aux médias sociaux
et omis de les casser
le congrès américain a documenté
l'ampleur des faux compte twitter russe
il y en avait des milliers
le représentant jim prime ce que vous
venez d'entendre quoique des tentatives
de déstabilisation russe pourrait aussi
être tentée chez nous au canada
l'enjeu linguistique entre le français
et l'anglais par exemple pourraient
pense-t-il être un terreau fertile
si je suis assis au kremlin je me dis je
vais me trouver une façon de raviver ce
genre de tensions et de créer de
l'antagonisme au sein de la société
canadienne
je serais surpris qu'il ne soit pas une
douzaine à penser à ça présentement lors
de la tragédie de la mosquée de québec
plusieurs faux comptes russe fermé
depuis par twitter ont profité de
l'attentât dans les heures qui ont suivi
pour propager des forces nouvelles comme
celle ci qui pose la question
mieux qu'aux états unis et qui affirme
faussement que le tireur a crié allah
ouakbar 17 autres messages qui laisse
entendre que le suspect serait des
réfugiés syriens
l'idée que l'attentât de québec
finalement ça serait les réfugiés
arrivés au canada il également
et là on sait que ça va provoquer un
outrage d'une partie de la population
qui a déjà une vision assez négative
des réfugiés jamin du col et chercheurs
spécialisés dans les enjeux de médias
sociaux et de radicalisation violente
comment influencer le déchirement ou la
polarisation d'une société de la
meilleure manière si ce n'est donc
finalement de jouer sur les thématiques
qui sont les thématiques polarisantes au
sein d'une société et c'est pour ça que
les comptes de médias sociaux d'
influence russe qui vise à ajustement
jouer sur cette stratégie de
polarisation vont aborder des questions
comme l'immigration la sécurité le
terrorisme pour jouer justement sur ce
point de débat ça a été je pense
l'événement à cannes a dit que plus fait
jaser la planète entière donc il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de tweets sur le web
qui parlait de la tente au québec
la spécialité du chroniqueur jeff yates
et de débusquer les fausses nouvelles
pour lui il n'est pas clair que les
fausses informations diffusées par les
contes russes cibler précisément un
auditoire canadien je pense pas qu'on
puisse dire là vraiment on a la preuve
en ce moment il ya tout plein
d'explications qui sont passés le
résultat final semblable donc même si
c'est non intentionnelle ces jo zola de
ces réseaux la de rbo donne de l'oxygène
à ses messages lol et les permanences
propager de plus en plus nos collègues
de siby ci ont découvert que les faux
comptes russes ont envoyé des milliers
de messages à thématique canadienne du
lot peu notre message semble pour le
moins intriguant
auxerre
ici nous sommes au lendemain d'une
controverse au sujet des joueurs de
football américain qui s'agenouille
durant leur hymne national pour
protester contre les injustices sociales
ce jour là la ligue canadienne de
football prend position dans le débat
concernant ses propres joueurs qui se
sont exprimés à leur façon pour nos
visiteurs ont respecté la liberté
d'expression pendant l'hymne national
canadien
sans attendre le même jour 24 faux
comptes russe des formes le message en
affirmant que la ligue canadienne
manifestaient contre son hymne national
ce qui est intéressant dans ce cas là
par contre ces convois qui aimerait
vraiment un effort coordonné
donc on a vu qu'il ya quelque chose qui
a touché 1 ère dans cette opération là
donc ce message en particulier il y
avait un intérêt à vouloir le partager
toute chaîne publique nrk évidemment
qu'on lui parle de son actualité à lui
ont près les comptes et le meilleur
jeune cinquantaine donc tu vois que ya
répondu où il ya 8 8 et des messages
envoyés par parce qu'on fait quelques
recherches sur tout et tulle nous ont
permis de repérer plusieurs utilisateurs
canadiens qui ont échangé de nombreux
messages avec les faux comptes russe qui
visiblement savait les faire réagir
on parle de 5,14 beau et puis l'autre
quelqu'un qui se décrit comme étant un
canadien qui répond à ce pays qui disent
pas qu'ils se parlent
keith qui s'excitent pour ça pour ces
informations leur que ça démontre
vraiment comment l'information peut
circuler rapidement pu partir de loin
puis sera mans c'est ici dans les
discussions politiques sur twitter ce
qu'on voit effectivement c'est quand il
ya une traction quand il ya une il ya
une écoute auprès d'une audience
actuellement qui pourrait être
l'audience canadienne pour des messages
qui sont relayés par ses comptes là
alors on peut dire qu'effectivement
abandonné la sauce peut prendre une
certaine manière
[Musique]
après la pause les fausses nouvelles ça
évite au g7 dans charlevoix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces actions inacceptables sont entrés de
faire mal à ses propres citoyens ont mis
à l'arrêt du sommet du g7 dans
charlevoix
le premier ministre trudeau reçoit son
homologue français sur fond de guerre
commerciale avec les états unis si nous
ne réagissions pas la décision
unilatérale est illégale américaine nous
renoncerions collectivement notre
souveraineté
l'incertitude plane sur la présence de
dents dont 30 à la table on sait que le
président entrant peut être imprévisible
par moments mais toutes les indications
sont qu'il sera là c'est le genre
d'événement qui génère énormément
d'attention dans les médias du monde
entier mais aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux
on a donc décidé d'en profiter pour
surveiller le web en temps réel pour
voir la rapidité avec laquelle les
nouvelles du g7 se répandront avec une
attention particulière bien sûr sur
celle qui nous apparaissent douteuses
vous avez nommé aujourd'hui vous avez
chacun des mots clés des comptes astrees
avec notre collègue des finances
on a réuni une demi douzaine d'étudiants
pour nous aider à suivre le fil des
événements si vous voyez quelque chose
devant un peu louche la main puis on va
regarder ça ensemble
histoire de ne rien manquer on a aussi
demandé au professeur de journalisme
jean hugues roy de concevoir un
programme informatique qui recueillera
tous les messages qui passeront sur
twitter pour quelques dizaines de mots
clés pertinents g7 pendant 72 heures 6
heures une somme est en anglais la
malbaie charlevoix danger cette manif
manifestation et quand ils entrent ou
les magazines dans une base de données
ça je laisserai le premier ministre hugo
qui qui préside le g7 dire un peu de
temps après le point de presse pré
sommet de justin trudeau et emmanuel
macron une fausse nouvelle plutôt
bizarre commence à faire son chemin sur
les réseaux sociaux
regardez bien cet extrait repris par un
compte twitter dans les heures suivantes
et trouvez l'erreur
vous avez trouvé
sinon voici ce que l'utilisateur twitter
dit avoir découvert selon lui justin
trudeau est en train de perdre un de ses
sourcils en seulement 72 heures
l'univers twitter s'enflamme pour
l'histoire et dans les jours qui suivent
c'est le déluge sur internet ça part
plutôt au départ d'une moquerie c'est de
se moquer du personnel politique
on passa tient ce qu'ils veulent
fabriquer les fake news se disent tiens
on a on a un bon un bon filon là il ya
quelque chose à exploiter qu on repérait
des citoyens qui faisait ça pour rire et
on va l'exploiter
parmi les médias qui ont repris la
nouvelle une chaîne russe proposait sur
son site en anglais un sondage trudeau
portait-il de faux sourcil au g7
notre programme informatique ne manque
pas de repérer le mot ibra au sourcil en
anglais à plusieurs reprises sur
l'autoroute twitter mais pas ds dans
l'ensemble de la base de données il
apparaît bon sang neuf fois ils sont un
espace entre haye et brown en a
davantage
366 occurrence alors un sujet qui la
cimade au sujet de
rapidement fait jaser affaire a pris des
proportions telles que certains médias
traditionnels ont senti le besoin de s'y
intéresser dont cnn sur un ton
humoristique experte à l'appui le
verdict est tombé par les oranje ce
n'était donc pas défaut et vérification
faite à ottawa aussi on nous confirme
qu'il s'agit de ses vrais sourcil et ce
n'est qu'un début
une autre manche est surprenante
apparaît sur les écrans de notre équipe
de surveillance des réseaux sociaux et
le sommet n'est toujours pas
officiellement commencé notre
collaborateur alexandre gagnon remarque
titre à la véracité douteuses manchette
à droite déjà un site annonce que trump
sera exclu de l'entente finale la
nouvelle est vite reprise par d'autres
pages web
c'est ainsi qu'on appelle hyper
partisans dans le cadre washington sol
c'est un site qui plaisait aux gens qui
n'aiment pas donner trop visiblement le
titre de l'article même faux rejoint
rapidement un public friand de ce genre
de nouvelles
gino l'article qui te trouver et
partager 5.5 5500 c'est beaucoup plus
facile de faire réagir les gens avec des
fausses informations parce qu'on peut
inventer tous les détails qu'on veut
pour aller chercher la réaction qu'on va
aller chercher
[Musique]
après deux jours de vigie internet sur
le g7
on constate que la fosse manchette sur
l'exclusion de dans notre homme de
l'entente provenant d'une obscure site
de nouvelle s'est propagée de façon
assez exceptionnelle entre plusieurs
pages facebook qui ont partagé la scène
avec la même approche pour mon et le
site où on a repéré la nouvelle
washington source a été créé il ya à
peine 48 heures le site est écrit le 6
juin
on est lui tient déjà ses cet article
publié l'article qui le plus partagé sur
le geste sur le web au complet on voit
le 31 mai le partage sur les réseaux
sociaux
aujourd'hui vous avez un écosystème
sociaux numériques de l'information dans
lequel vous pouvez avoir avec un compte
facebook autant d'influencé que certains
médias traditionnels
on ne sait donc cet article ne
fonctionnait que tous les médias très
remarquée dans le top 6 le on est
d'autant plus prompt à croire à quelque
chose qu'on a le sentiment que beaucoup
de gens là croit déjà ça vous fonde
j'allais dire en toute bonne foi à
croire vous aussi et à devenir l'idiot
utile qui va contribuer à partager cette
rumeur ou cette fête news puisque vous
même vous allez lalique et la partager
et ses tubes i expo à défaut de pouvoir
parler à un responsable chez washington
source nous avons tout de même retracé
un investisseur du site
selon lui l'article n'était pas une
fausse nouvelle il admet cependant que
le titre pouvait constituer un raccourci
qui aurait mérité après le fait d'être
ajustés je pense faut apprendre aux gens
tourner ses pouces cette fois avant de
partager une information que ce soit
avec l'exemple de la nouvelle sur le g7
ou des sourciers le justin trudeau
on voit que des informations du genre
peuvent facilement être crue est partagé
par le public
peu importe le média qui les diffusent
malheureusement ce qu'on a vu les études
tombe
heinz qui sait que les forces nouvelles
vont se propager beaucoup plus vite que
livre le meuble après la pause
l'armée canadienne sur la ligne de front
de la désinformation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
juin 2018 des troupes américaines et
d'autres pays alliés se déploie dans les
pays baltes voisins de la russie
parmi eux se trouvent des canadiens
rassurez vous ce n'est qu'un exercice
militaire
ici les canadiens simulent des
manoeuvres dans un quartier pour
lettonie sénat sociale est là qui le
lois internationales la russie juste à
côté a annexé la crimée en 2014 depuis
l'an dernier plus de 450 militaires
canadiens sont stationnés en lettonie
dans une base en banlieue de riga ils
font partie d'un groupement tactique de
l'otan qui compte plus d'un millier de
soldats provenant de huit pays c'est le
lieutenant-colonel french qui commande
le groupe une sorte de force de
dissuasion
nous sommes ici pour protéger nos alliés
cette époque quelque chose qui est
agressif dès qu'elle a mis les pieds en
lettonie en 2017 l'armée canadienne a
goûté au travers de la désinformation
disons que nos militaires ont reçu un
accueil pour le moins particulier sur
internet parce que l'article 10 cd
allusion au fait que le groupement
tactique c'était à l'agglo matap singh
et du canada dont liz est la photo de
de grâce à habiller un sous-vêtement de
femmes pour démonter que les soldats
canadiens sont tous comme ça puis sami
un événement tellement que la grippe est
tactile vous pourrez vous protéger si
son s'ils sont comme ça grosso au
royaume n'a plus aucun lien avec l'armée
canadienne il purge une peine de prison
pour meurtre
l'armée a donc rapidement corriger le
tir on a fait un entrevue pas mal
immédiatement après que la nouvelle
sortie le but d information c'est acide
du consul et d'une manière pour une
collector
[Musique]
la lettonie comme d'autres pays baltes
de l'otan est une ancienne république
soviétique
une bonne partie des lettons sont
russophones ils ont donc pu voir passer
cet autre article en ruche qui laisse
entendre que l'arrivée des militaires
canadiens va faire augmenter le prix des
loyers à riga ce qui est faux dit le
colonel
je peux vous dire que le nombre de
personnes qui habitent en ville qui loue
des appartements ac - exane
il annonce cadettes à riga maïs etc -
cinq parfois de l'information circule
même en anglais sur des sujets à
conséquences beaucoup plus graves
ce site novo rossi a tout d annoncer en
juin 2010 est la mort de douces canadien
dans des affrontements dans la région du
donbass dans l'est de l'ukraine
c'est un exemple parfait de la
désinformation
golvin note la présence est en fait très
loin de cet acte l'article raconte son
histoire
photos à l'appui mais une simple
recherche sur internet permet de voir
que l'une a été prise en irak en 2015
une autre aux funérailles d'un militaire
à hamilton en ontario en 2014
et puis celle ci de 2008 en france lors
d'une cérémonie en l'honneur de
canadiens disparus en 1944 pour les
aider dans leur bataille contre la
désinformation le canada et d'autres
pays de l'otan s'appuie sur le travail
de divers organismes l'edf air lab une
sorte de laboratoire de recherche
numérique avancé est un de ceux là
on surveille divers réseaux sociaux et
médias sur internet pour identifier
toute désinformation potentiel et on
essaie de réagir aussi vite qu'on peut
pour nous assurer que leur impact soit
le moins significatif possible en mai
dernier une autre nouvelle importante
concernant l'est de week-end retient
leur attention
trois soldats canadiens y serait mort en
zone de conflit dans l'explosion d'une
mine des américains auraient aussi été
blessés
les pôles manganèse l'histoire était
fausse
ça nous a pris probablement moins d'une
demi heure elle est confirmée auprès des
forces américaines en europe
n'importe quel journaliste qui se
respecte aurait fait cette manne
vérification cinq jours plus tard un
site basé à montréal globaux reasearch
point ca publie un texte faisant
référence à deux possibles morts
canadiens au donbass sans citer de
source
l'auteur de l'article note que les
médias traditionnels font comme si rien
ne s'était passé
peut-être lit-on plus loin veux-t-on
terre la faire parce que le canada est
supposée être la base seulement en
mission de formation
la façon dont je dis ça c'est comme si
c'était quelque chose de normal
comme si le gouvernement canadien
cachait des choses depuis toujours et
que les médias traditionnels en étaient
complices
a riga le centre d'excellence en
communication stratégique de l'otan
travaillent avec l'edf air lab
ça fait déjà plusieurs mois que son
équipe surveille ce qui est publié sur
le site globo lui search.ch qui a aussi
une version française mondialisation.ca
dans certaines campagnes de
désinformation on a vu que ce site était
un des points centraux exemple cette
histoire où l'on rapportait que les
états unis envoyait apparemment 3600
chars d'assaut en europe en préparation
pour la guerre
l'edf airs l'awb avait rapidement publié
une vérification des faits de cette
histoire pour conclure que l'article
avait multiplié par vingt le nombre réel
de chars d'assaut
l'analyse du dr lab faisait la
démonstration du rôle joué par globo
reasearch dans la dissémination de cette
fausse information est une partie
importante d'un réseau qui répand de la
désinformation pro kremlin en langue
anglaise
le site montréalais fait partie de six
ans que surveille l'organisme de riga
star c'est selon selon les les gens qui
n'ont jamais répéter un million de
visites par mois selon jeff yates le
fait que ceux ci reprennent des textes
d'autres sites moins connus n'est pas
sans conséquence c'est que le second
diaz à son vote permettra d auteurs
d'écrire sur le site et d'utiliser la
crédibilité du site pour pour publier
leurs articles
c'est peut-être pas intentionnel ça les
fait un peu de masquer la source ce
qu'on appelle du blanchiment de
désinformation quand une désinformation
et reprise par un site internet qui ne
semble pas reliés au kremlin
mais qui proposent néanmoins la même
lecture des choses
l'adresse de globo louis search et
mondialisation.ca est ici dans le vieux
montréal
les sites appartiennent à un organisme
sans but lucratif dirigée par michel
chossudovsky un professeur d'économie de
l'université d'ottawa
il a refusé notre demande d'entrevue sur
ces questions et déplore ce faire
dépeindre comme un agent de moscou
que des gens affiliés à l'otan s'en
prennent à son site constitue selon lui
une atteinte à la liberté d'expression
par une entité militaire
plusieurs auteurs écrivent sur globo
reasearch et mondialisation.ca on y
trouve aussi divers textes et vidéos de
michel chossudovsky sur une variété de
sujets nous savons que les entités liés
à al qaïda incluant l'état islamique
sont une création des services de
renseignement notamment dacia
michel chossudovsky nous dit que tous
les articles passent par lui mais le
site décline toute responsabilité
on y lit que les opinions exprimées dans
un article n'engagent que leurs auteurs
et que le site ne sera pas tenu
responsable pour des erreurs ou
informations incorrectes ou inexactes et
des sceaux is c'est si facile de
prétendre que vous n'êtes qu'un site
d'opinion alors que vous êtes pourtant
un média avec une ligne éditoriale du
point
alors je crois qu'il joue ici dans cette
zone grise qui n'a pas été réglementé
plus d'un an et demi après sa
publication
l'article sur les chars d'assaut
américaine a été corrigé le mois dernier
en fait le nombre de 3600 chars
n'apparaît plus michel chossudovsky dit
qu'il y avait une confusion dans les
nombres sur le terrain en lettonie les
soldats canadiens doivent poursuivre
leur mission en tenant compte des effets
que peuvent avoir les fausses nouvelles
sur la population
à quel point c'est important pour les
pays de l'otan d'avoir l'appui des gens
dans les populations locales
lors de vos exercices c'est fondamental
il faut qu'ils appuient le temps parce
que ce sont eux qui financent ces
budgets et qui lui fournit ses soldats
john
la population d'après moi à oui ah parce
que de tristes angers l'evora réaction
quand je parlais à la population petit
coup de sonde dans les rues de riga
lettonie de la beauté ils font beaucoup
de bruit et a donc je travaille à côté
et je pense que ce serait mieux de
donner cet argent aux gens je pense que
cette situation irrite la russie mais je
pense que la présence de le temps est
nécessaire
autrement personne ne pourra retenir la
russie ce sont les américains qui sont
venus ici pour défendre notre patrie
comme on dit mais nous défendre de qui
j'aime le dialecte et non les six nous
coopérions avec la russie ce serait
mieux
l'enjeu ne semble donc pas faire
l'unanimité et certains l'étang
russophone par est encore attaché à la
russie dans ce débat où chacun a droit à
son opinion
une chose demeure tous devront à tout le
moins s'entendre sur ce qui est vrai et
ce qu'il faut après la pause
facebook répond à nos questions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le canada les états-unis l'ukraine et 14
pays de l'union européenne ont annoncé
l'expulsion de plus d'une centaine de
diplomates russes
en réponse à l'empoisonnement de
l'ancien espion sergueï skripal
au royaume uni le canada excuses quatre
russes qui auraient utilisé leur statut
diplomatique pour entre autres
s'immiscer dans sa démocratie
enfin quelques jours plus tard invité à
préciser le contexte de ces expulsions
le premier ministre évoque des exemples
de désinformation pour moi c'est tout à
fait inacceptable que la russie a choisi
ce de ceux de se mêler dans l'opinion
publique canadienne
dans une réaction qui nous a fait
parvenir
l'ambassadeur de russie au canada
alexander d'artière parle d'un récit
arbitraire antirusse plein de mensonges
et de contre façon
la russie dit il n'a pas d'agenda caché
pendant qu'à ottawa on braque les
projecteurs sur la russie à washington
les élus questionne le rôle de facebook
comme outil pour des ingérences de
l'étranger
le grand patron de facebook sont le
besoin de faire son mea culpa ce qu'on a
vu au terme des élections américaines
s'étaient beaucoup d'opérations de
désinformation et d'abus de notre réseau
pour tromper les gens système depuis on
a investi beaucoup en personnel ans
dans et en technologie pour attaquer ce
problème de france
facebook a aussi dû témoigner devant le
parlement canadien durant le premier
trimestre de 2010 8
on a désactivé environ 583 millions de
faux comptes en seulement trois mois en
prévision des élections au canada
facebook dit avoir mis en place une
adresse courriel d'urgence pour les
candidats et partis politiques afin de
prévenir les risques de piratage de
leurs pages facebook en juillet dernier
à quelques mois des élections
américaines de mi mandat
facebook a fermé 32 autres contes et
page d'utilisateurs en faisant des liens
avec l' affaire des faux comptes russe
de 2016
ça ressemblait ce qui est arrivé en 2016
mais c'était différent c'est clair que
même si on est maintenant meilleur pour
identifier les risques
nos adversaires ont aussi évolué dans
leurs méthodes
par exemple ils utilisent des téléphones
cellulaires pour dissimuler leur
localisation
ok l'an dernier une des agences
canadiennes du renseignement le centre
de la sécurité des télécommunications a
indiqué dans un rapport être aux aguets
contre les cyber menaces visons le
processus démocratique lors d'élections
au canada vous attendez vous à ce que le
processus électoral 2019 au canada l'an
prochain soit la cible de tentatives de
manipulation de l'étranger la tendance
est à la hausse de manipulation par
l'étranger si vous parlez d'état venez
faire d'interférences au canada c'est
quelque chose qu'on a à l'oeil
andrée boucher rappelle que le canada
avec son siège au g7 et à l'otan par
exemple pourrait attirer l'attention de
certains
si à ce moment là on est on est le sujet
on est au centre de la conversation
internationale ça augmente les chances
en fait que d'autres intervenants ans à
venir interférer dans nos conversations
démocratique si vous me demandez si on a
vu des faux comptes qui tente
spécifiquement d'influencé une élection
au canada
je peux vous dire qu'on n'a pas vu au
canada ce genre d'activité inauthentique
et coordonnées le canada n'est pas pour
autant épargnés par les faux comptes
étrangers
le mois dernier jeffs a jeté un oeil sur
plusieurs comptes iraniens cette fois
fermé par facebook
ça lui a permis de remonter vers un site
internet qui affirme sans nuance que
justin trudeau avait des faux sourcil au
g7 sans me poser de questions
les responsables du site ne communique
que par courriel et refuse de
s'identifier
ils disent n'avoir de lien avec aucun
gouvernement
[Musique]
en france le président a décidé de
prendre les grands moyens contre la
désinformation en mai 2010 est emmanuel
macron n'avait toujours pas digéré ce
qu'il percevait comme une intervention
de médias russes dans sa campagne
présidentielle
il leur avait d'ailleurs fait savoir
lors d'un point de presse
tout juste à côté de son homologue russe
il était grave que des organes de presse
étrangers sous quelques influences que
ce soit je ne le sais est interférer en
répandant des contrevérités grave dans
le cadre d'une campagne démocratique
puis en janvier dernier il annonçait
ceci dit décidé que nous allions faire
évoluer notre dispositif juridique pour
protéger la vie démocratique de ces
fausses nouvelles
un texte de loi sera prochainement
déposée à ce sujet un projet de loi sur
la manipulation de l'information vise à
permettre de s'adresser à un juge pour
faire cesser la diffusion d'une fausse
information en période électorale
c'est un message très clair c'est à tous
ceux qui fabriquent défectueux c'est
l'ornière les gars open bar s'est
terminée maintenant vous rentrez plus
c'est pas gratuit il y aura un cessera
risques et il y aura un coût nous
perçons à l'intervention de monsieur
nicolas dupont aignan certains évoquent
une atteinte à la liberté d'expression
vous allez donner le pouvoir au juge le
pouvoir de dire quelle est la vérité est
une fausse information
ou n'est-ce pas une fausse information
je suis partagé la liberté d'expression
c'est nos droits les plus précieux
alors quand pour le limiter ça prend des
raisons de maudire de bonnes raisons les
gens qui foncent volontairement ils
abusent de leur liberté d'expression et
abusent de leur droit
ça ça me dérange mais ça me dérangerait
aussi qu'on limite la liberté
d'expression devrait-on censurer les
fausses nouvelles on en parle tout de
suite après cette pause
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
twitter et facebook se sont attiré
plusieurs critiques quand ils ont décidé
de fermer des comptes qu'il juge fo ou
qu'ils avaient contrevenu à leurs règles
quand ces entreprises ne prennent des
décisions un de vouloir fermer dès qu'on
s'a des conséquences pis c'est pas comme
un gouvernement qui décide d'avoir
certaines politiques et on n'aime pas ça
on peut voter quatre ans plus tard et
changer de gouvernement
même le président américain dans notre
up est irrité par la situation dans une
série de tweets au sujet des réseaux
sociaux le 18 août dernier dans nos
craintes affirmé laisser tout le monde
participe est bon ou mauvais et chacun
devra se faire sa propre idée
facebook considère qu'elle n'a pas à
être un arbitre de la vérité la
compagnie a conclu des partenariats avec
des journalistes pour vérifier les
forces nouvelles qui lui sont rapportées
ce qui lui permet d'intervenir quand un
article jugé faux par un de nos
partenaires de vérification des faits on
avise immédiatement les gens qui ont
partagé l'article pour leur dire qu'il a
été vérifié et qu'il est considéré faut
on s'assure aussi que si quelqu'un
d'autre ça prête à partager ce même
article il verra paraître message à
l'écran pour lui rappeler qu'il y à une
vérification des faits et on va lui
demander
êtes vous certain de vouloir le partage
est peut-être plus important encore pour
facebook parvient à réduire en moyenne
de 80%
la diffusion de ces articles qui ont été
vérifiés et jugé faux le chef de la
direction de twitter se fie aussi aux
journalistes pour sonner l'alertent aux
fausses nouvelles sur son réseau
facebook limite ferme des comptes ça
prend des bonheurs et donc faut que les
phoques les paramètres soient claires
loukil le sens commun
non je pense qu'on c'est un livre qui
s'écrit pour fur et à mesure que
l'histoire avance
la technologie va continuer à évoluer ou
si on n'a pas fini de se poser des
questions des solutions on va adopter
aujourd'hui el materi mais demain c'est
vraiment y arriver le show où c'est que
ces entreprises ne décide de tard
certains disent qu on est rendus
paraître dans un environnement où ce
n'est pas entendue sur facebook des
pantins du point pendant que les
technologies évoluent que les géants du
web et les gouvernements s'adaptent le
pouvoir de choisir entre l'information
qui est vrai est celle qui est faux
selon continuera d'appartenir à chacun
de nous je pense aussi qu'il faut tenir
un discours en discours de
responsabilité en montrant que tout le
monde est responsable c'est à nous de
faire le discernement entre vrai message
ou un message qu'il est capable tout à
fait ridicule mais qu'on n'aurait pas
tendance à croire maintenant il ya un
travail pédagogique incessants a mené
pendant des années et des années avant
que le tri des fêtes news deviennent
aussi répandu et pour certains aussi
naturel que le tri des déchets
c'est déjà interdit par la loi
électorale au canada de tenter
d'influencer une élection en publiant
une fausse déclaration sur un candidat
mais ottawa va aller encore plus loin
avec son projet de loi 76 et empêcher
toute forme de dépenses électorales d'un
pays étranger et notamment inscrire
clairement dans la loi qu'un état
étranger ne peut pas exercer une
influence indue sur un électeur canadien
c'est tout pour ce soir si vous avez de
vraies informations nous transmettre
pour nos enquêtes
rendez vous sur notre page web où vous
pouvez le faire au moyen de notre
plateforme sécurisée source anonyme au
nom de toute l'équipe merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là et reviens-nous la
semaine prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]